Hey, everyone, I had to set everything up
for just a moment, and you know mac os and
Apple software.
So hey I'm Christoph I work at Facebook as front-end engineer
in JavaScript infrastructure team. I'm going
to tell you how evolved our front end source
space. And I'll teach you how to do large
scale tool assisted co‑changes to your JavaScript
code effectively. And the word that we use
for this at Facebook is codemod,code modification,we
kind of invented it, that's just what question
call it. And at Facebook sometimes we use
it inter change establish sometimes it'smanual
change, sometimes it's an automatic change,
it always refers to large scale changes to
a big portion of our code base (Manual) at
Facebook we have tens of thousands of judgment
modules and we need to make sure that the
health of our code base is very good and we
have a good handle on that, what's more is
that we want to enable every engineer at Facebook
to move fast, even with breaking changes.
We often add new shiny abstractions, new language
features because it's always easy to add something
new, we tell people, use that, use Latin‑‑
not var anymore, we never go back and tell
people, hey, we need to clean this up, can
you deprecate your code and remove it. It's
always really hard to get rid of deprecated
code, especially if you have thousands of
callers around your code base (Deprecated)
browsers also new capabilities, frameworks
gain new features as well. We need to somehow
handle this. Everything just becomes more
complex. The problem is that even though we
add all those new features, the health of
our code base more and more declines because
we have multiple ways of doing the same thing.
We also want to encourage people to always
just write code using the new patterns, but,
especially if you're new at a company or new
at a code base and you just started looking
at it and you true to figure out how something
is done you usually look at how other people
around you did the same thing, then you discovered
all the code, you tonight know if it's deprecated
or not, you use the code around you and you
write it like it was the latest and greatest
thing, like more and more deprecated code
even though you shouldn't be using the patterns
anymore. We often have hundreds of thousands
of calls of something, we have a web UI that
allows you to search quickly across all the
code. I had to make a change and I was looking
at how many lines of code and how many invalid
patterns are we using there that we have to
update, and in this case there were almost
a hundred thousand results and then it tells
you, oh, I cannot display this to you because
it would crash your browser. So going through
every call set manually is not a solution.
It's not even an option for us in some cases.
This is a codemod they ran on our code base,
we have a tool called codemod, it's very simple,
it's an internal tool, I have this string
and I want to replace it with this other thing.
This has served us really well to evolve our
code base over time, it's really good when
you do a simple rename, you rename JSCONUS
and up load to the web site and you're done.
But we're way beyond simple renames and also
the syntax for JavaScript becomes more and
more complex and also ambiguous, so we can't
really use regx anymore so this is something
I actually ran at our UI class at Facebook.
It has been around for a long time, but we
use an early class of ES 1 , ECMI script it
was just final iced now called ES2015. Hopefully
it's 2015, if I say ES6, I'll buy you a beer
later. So I haven't done regX code much in
a long time, I figured I can do this with
a renaleX the problem I tried to solve was
add a new call to create an instance of the
URI class instead of calling as a function,
we had a pattern for the same path, we had
a code to allow tin stance of this class,
with new and without new. figured, okay, I
can do this with a regX. So I wrote one regX
didn't catch all the cases, wrote another,
didn't catch all the cases either, wrote a
few more, then at some point I was in a mess
for some reason everything was broken because
one of my regX wasn't very good,I probably
had a star, or a dot or something, I was just
really frustrated, then I rewrote this using
an EST base codemod and it was don't in two
minutes and basically two lains of code. I
mention ASTs, codemods that operate on the
AST, abstract syntax representation of JavaScript
instead of source text representation. They
can really help us make a difference. If you
build a strong codemod for an API change you're
making you can rework and apply it every time
you make a change to the code that you're
trying to build. And what about rebasing?
When you manually update your code on a long‑lived
branch when working on a new feature, you
have to redo changes potentially every time
when you pull from master or something like
that. With AST codemods I can rerun them before
I push my change, done. But, I also want to
talk about the frustration around the deaspiration
that one often feels when they're thinking
of making or braking API change. Good codemods
are really hard. And I'm sure, everyone of
you, at least once, decided not to run a codemod
because it seemed too difficult and they just
kept the old API around, didn't make a breaking
change, it just wasn't, you didn't have the
right tooling for that. However, quite often,
there's simply no other way around codemods.
We can't just rewriting write our entire code
base because we have a couple of bad abstractions.
We must find ways to evolve our code base
incrementally or well change complex systems
incrementally. With a clearly envisioned end
state in mind. At Facebook we hack everything
and I put up these posters around the product
infrastructure team and someone guestening
this and made their own version of it. I actually
like this better than the original title.
But we also need to be confident when we make
these large changes to the code base. There's
no point in running a codemod if it disrupts
every single engineer at your whole company.
The whole point of this is not to break anything
and tone able every engineer to move faster.
And codemod tools help us do this. And the
tool that we build at Facebook is called JS
code shift it was built by Felix Kling, he
built it more than a year ago then he kept
it secret for a really long time. He was sitting
next to me at the time at Facebook and we
casually talked about this new API that I
wanted to build and I had this idea of what
I wanted to build and I just didn't know how
to get there. It was impossible to do. And
then he was like, oh, yeah, so I built this
tool, it's probably not very good, and I was
look, okay, let's take a look at this. I looked
at it, I was like holy shit this is amazing,
we have to Open Source this and we the. This
is really good. Let's dive into how I got
started with this kind of codemod work. It's
exciting to be able to talk about how we built
a relay framework. I know if you heard about
prelate it's a data framework on top of fame
work. This year at React JSCON we wanted to
build a new API, wanted to move away from
create graph QL.mix in to relay.create container.
So in relay we used to have this mix‑in,
but used internal React APIs we couldn't shift
to Open Source API, it broke all the time
because we act changed all the time as well.
And we also couldn't‑‑ because we were
using a mix‑in we weren't sueable to support
ES 2016 class components, it was also a way
cleaner implementation. We really wanted to
move to this. But the problem is, this completely
changed the full public API relay and admittedly
it's not a big public API, but it changed
the entire API. At that point in time, herbally
this year, there were already hundreds of
files using‑‑ written using relay, and
the product teams using product‑‑ was
moving really fast. Building this enough API
took about a month to complete. I built a
codemod and had to run it at least ten to
fifteen times to test different stages of
the new API. If I had done this manually,
while we were building this new API for a
month, I would have had to change those hundreds
of files manually every time when some product
developer changed something and it would be
a huge mess. It's painful, just to get a better
idea of here's the before and after. It doesn't
matter if you know relay or React, t matters
that you have pattern matching capabilities
in your brain and just compare those those
code pieces side by side the left side is
before the right side after. If you ever removed
a mix in and made a higher order component
yourself you know what the challenges are
involved here. But in this case, the original
example, I guess this laser pointer doesn't
work that well here, we had a mix‑in up
there and statics the new version didn't have
the mix‑in anymore, and then we had on‑line
fifteen the relay.create container that was
thereabout before, and then also we moved
the stat ticks into the secondary argument,
to the function call. And traditionally we
would solve this with regx, right. A lot you
this doesn't seem that difficult, I can probably
do this with a renaleX, I could maybe do it,
I wouldn't be confident and I'm sure it would
break badly. And here's why, I could probably
bulled a reg X from the example before, look
at the variation of a similar module on the
right, it's just a different developer built
a similar module with a different code convention.
This had a second mix‑in so we can't remove
the whole mix‑in line, had different stat
ticks and different in how it was exported.
But also for this change I had to add a new
module that didn't exist before and remove
an old one from the require Blog. We have
human code conventions as everyone does, I
had to enter the new requirement statement
at the right alphabetical locations, this
is just a lot of work with regx. You know.
This is what I wanted to show you what can
be different from one module to another module
and quite often that night be two people working
on the same team, working on the same product,
you know, and the whole point of this is to
output some code that looks like a human had
written this. So, I need to figure out how
can I write a codemod that looks like I wrote
this code. But there's more, what does this
piece of JavaScript mean? Does anyone know?
Anyone seen this before? Everyone's quite.
So we don't actually know because it depends
on what context this is used in. So this is
an entirely different piece of JavaScript.
Anyone, anyone has an idea? Everyone's shaking
their head. So the first win, this is actually
a block statement with a label called JavaScript
and the value that it maps to is a binary
expression is awesome and concatenates that
together. But the second one, this is an object
expression where the key is JavaScript, it
only has one property and the it's awesome
I've talked about why‑‑ what is JS code
shift? What does it do for us, simple description
is an ST toST codemod, we need to dig deeper
and figure out what tools are involved and
what concepts do we need to understand. So
let's ask ourselves what do we actually want
to do here? We want to take one piece of JavaScript
and output a different piece of JavaScript,
and we're going to operate on the ST, so we
need to parse JavaScript source code into
an ST then we need to find the nodes that
we want to replace, create new nodes that
we want to insert, then update the EST at
the right location and then print it back
into JavaScript source ideally with proper
formatting and it should look like a human
wrote this. I want to point out that all we
do here is simple tree operations. As Front‑End
developers you should all know what this is
doing, right? We're dealing with the DOM all
the time we find, create and update nodes
it's same for ASTs, let's look at these step‑by‑step.
First up parse, I talk about the abstract
syntax tree. I'm pretty sure most of you are
look nope, sounds like stat tick analysis,
it doesn't matter if you know ASTs or don't,
I'm going to show you what an AST looks like
and you can time me if you want to. There's
a tool that we built at Facebook called AST
explorer. I'm go going to‑‑ (Explorer)
cool, I'm at the demo. This is not very big,
this is better. All right, cool. So this the
the AST explorer, you can follow along if
you have your laptop open. All it does is
it gives you two panels, there's the code
you can write, and then the AST representation
of the same code. AST tonight be scared, it's
just a simple JSON data structure, this tool
helps visualize, in this sample code we have
two statements and one of them is a variable
declaration and one of them is a function
declaration, it's not very exciting, it's
just‑‑ it's initialized using an array
expression. It's called tips and that's an
identifier. Let's look at some other code.
So, I showed you this example before, right.
And you were shaking your head and you're
like what are you talking about, this doesn't
make sense, this looks like an October. No,
actually this is a block statement. It has
a label here, the label is called JavaScript,
and the body of the block statement is binary
expression. So, now, let's wrap it in parens
and now suddenly this is an object expression,
it has one property and then this property
has a key that's an identifier called name
and then a value with a binary expression.
That is awesome expression. All right, cool.
Remember what an object expression looks like,
I'll go over this in a moment, this is important.
We also can do function calls, a little bit
of German here. In this case, this is also
important, there's a call expression, thecal
Lee is called hallow, and the arguments is
a string literal called JSConfEU. All right.
Let's do something quick, we can create a
class JSConfEU has awesome food. Does it have
awesome food? Yes, hell yeah! This probably
extends probably JSCONF, we can see this is
a class declaration, it's ID, it's name is
JSConfEU, it has a super class it extends
and then here it has a class body and it has
a method called has awesome food, and of course,
this somewhere returns true. So that's an
AST. So next I want to talk about create.
We're going to skip over find, I hope you
allow me to do this. I said before we're dealing
with a simple objected day the structure,
we could build up an object and‑‑ A
ST, you can do that but you tonight have type
guarantees and probably end up in a mess because
you make a Typo nothing works anymore, but
there's a project created by Ben jaw listic
anyone who used to work at Facebook, it has
a the similar syntax to Babels creation system.
This is an API to define AST types and then
it gives us a functional API to compose those
AST nodes, gives you type safety, tells you
when you cannot create an AST node with what
the type you in the mind. You saw the object
expression before, here on the left side we
define an object expression, basad on an expression
built up using properties and the field properties
is an array of property and you can property
right below that, property based on a node,
built up the kind the key and the value. The
kind is iter init, or setter, usually init,
we're scared of getter and setters, and then
there's‑‑ getters and setters, a key
(Getter) a field value that can be any expression,
the value can be any expression it can also
be an objects expression because objects expression
is based on an expression. On the right‑hand
side you can see how we build this up, basically
we get a function called objects expression
we pass in the property, and if we were to
print that code, it would print JavaScript
is awesome, over course depending ton context
it would add parens, otherwise it would be
a label statement and we don't know what to
do. There's more in JS code shift you can
type it out in a template literal and then
reparse that JS code and then you can actually‑‑
using substitution to output proper AST nodes.
And then, this is from an example that converts
four loops into a‑‑ loop. This is really
cool. Going to skip over update, hope you
allow me to to that use. We talked about parse
and create, let's talk about printing, this
is really hard. The project we're using for
in is recast. It was created by Ben newman
also. it's really awesome, gives us one API,
it's called recast drought print. What's the
point of 24?‑‑ what's the point of this‑‑
it‑‑ if you build a JS Compiler like
babble you don't care about the out put of
your transformed code (Don't really care)
the only thing that see it is output is the
browser, and we usually minute FYcode, if
you write a codemod you don't want to find
yourself in a situation where the code you
printed that you didn't even touch looks completely
different from before. If I do this, if I
run a codemod and I only change one tiny little
thing here and output looks component model
plately different and I run it on tens of
thousands of JavaScript modules every engineering
company is going to be annoyed by me. I don't
want any engineer to know I'm even doing this.
(Don't) you can provide options on what the
code style is, that you ear using in your
code, like indentation, what's even better,
it doesn't try to reprint the code you didn't
touch that's important, you're only changing
the things that you're actually changing.
And this is why we cannot just use Babel which
is a Compiler to to this not yet any stay
tuned. We talked about creating ST nodes and
hao we print the ST back into source code.
For find and update this is were JS code ties
it together, provides a neat little package
for you to do these AST codemods, in the past
we simply didn't have tool set enable us to
do this. We didn't have a standard for JSAST
a couple of years ago, we needed all these
tools before that. So let's do a demo, everyone
loves demos, we'll write a transform that
get rids of a hypothetical module called merge,
this is a module that exist in the three different
variations at Facebook and then I killed them
all at Facebook, they're not there anymore,
you can search the source code, it's not there,
I promise. Took all the arguments you pass
into it create add new object and created
all the passing properties into that new object
create add new object. Then we created a new
syntax for React in the beginning we realized
this is also awesome for objects we can use
the spread property, the three dots right
there that you see in the second lain to spread
all the properties of an object into a new
object, this is really powerful syntax. This
is not a standard yet, but we hope it will
be in ES 2016 or 2017. We're transforming
what you see in the first line to what you
see in the second line, ironically because
it's not a standard we're using Babel to transform
it into third lain for the browser. So this
is actually really funny. But given those
merge calls that could be nested. And that
could be nested merge calls and really deep
object structures you could have like whole
function in the merge calls like we had a
module that pulled in another module and then
merged new functions on to that module. This
is impossible to deal with in reg "X,"just
cannot be done. And how do you form at the
output, right? If we tonight have recast we
don't know how to format what we're doing
here. So, I ran this code it was no big deal,
I got rid about a thousand caller of this
function and four thousand callers of the
other two modules. No one noticed I had to
tell people afterwards. But it's gone and
now everyone's using the same thing and hopefully
will become a JavaScript standard. We have
a call expression here. It has three properties
(Gone) it has an identifier, I'm just going
to show you what the output is going to look
like. We need to parens as I showed you before.
It's going to be something like A, object
expressions be inlined. Two of them are spread
properties and one of them is a spread property.
All right. So we built this AST explorer and
we're look can we put JS code into this and
we did. Let me just so we got this live coding
environment here, it's really cool. So the
JS code API is basically you create a file
and it export asfunction that you can then
apply using a runner that runs in concurrently
across your entire code base. It gives you
the file, the source of the file and the API
of the code shift here on‑line five I'm
mapping it to J, J does everything for us,
writing it quite often that's why it's a short
one character identifier, we just pass the
thing into J and gives us this cool object,
it's magical you should read the documentation
(It's magical) this is the standard transform,
we find all the identifiers and we update
them. What we do is we just‑‑ reverse
the identifier. This is not a useful transform
unless you wrote the code originally right
to left. Any way cool thing is we can live
code here. If you're feeling German you cupper
case all of your code and it will still work,
which is awesome. These not very useful for
us. So we realized up there we need to operate
on call expressions, so this is a call expression.
And then it doesn't work. It's just the name
is actually call.name,‑‑ calllee.name,
now there's only merge, we don't want that.
So we want to replace it with an object expression,
that's what we saw before, and that we noticed
that takes an array. All right, that's cool,
it doesn't really do a lot, but we replaced
all the personal calls with object expression.
The problem is, this is not merge, and it's
also replaced. We don't want that. So this
gives us the ability to actually do pattern
matching here. All right, so now we're only
actually updating all the merge calls, and
then here, what we can do is, we map over
all the arguments so we have DST note here.
Then we have the arguments and then we return
a spread property with the argument. And boom,
we're done. Let me just format this, whatever.
Okay, but this is not what we wanted, all
right, we wanted to align the object, let's
look for the type here, object expression,
and then return all the properties of this
argument. Instead, all right, this doesn't
work, we actually need to use this really
awesome short version of ES2015 code with
recursive flat implementation. And boom, now
you can see that we successfully replaced
that personal module. So this is actually
just five lines of code. All right ( applause)
and to me 24 was like learning a super power.
When you learn how how to do this you can
write Babel plug‑ins,‑‑ so one more
thing, JavaScript now has a class creation
mechanism that we're supporting in React,
I figured we can transform React.create class
with a codemod, superintendent that fun? I
built a codemod can automatically do this,
if you look at the example, inlines it into
the new con instructor, it removes this access
and props because it's now local variable,
it does a lot of stuff. It also adds the prop
types later on. But, I talked a little bit
about this, we the a demo, just like a tiny
little sample code, that's not really fun,
you know. I found this project on get hundred
that's did he recall UI for React. Now let's
run this thing. Takes a little while, can
I wants over all the mix‑ins because we
don't have a good solution for that, but you
can build your own codemods to get rid of
them if you use them a lot. Takes a little
while. Tested it yesterday, I'm 200percent
sure it works really well. Now we're done
it used all the cores of my MacBook and transferred
all the files, yeah, looks about right. Nope
... can we send a pull request. Do I have
internet? I should probably push it. All right.
Where is it had are? Button is not working,
all right, here it is. All right (Applause)
there it is. This was fun (Laughing) that
was 845 files and probably 5‑10,000 lines
of code. If anyone asks I didn't touch the
code, I just wrote the JavaScript that wrote
the JavaScript, so my favorite editor is JavaScript.
But sometimes you cannot fix something automatically,
not possible, we tonight have all the tools
yet. What I found at Facebook is that you
can bribe really well with t‑shirts. So
at Facebook we have been using an early draft
of ES2015 classes for two and half years.
It allowed every edge near at the company
to move way faster that they could have using
ES 5 features. You have to consider that a
lot of engineers at Facebook didn't grow up
with JavaScript in their heart like all of
us here did. You know. The problem with our
implementation of classes was that we didn't
require soup erto be called in a child class
something that's required in ES2015. We had
about a thousand invalid callers, how did
I detect them I wrote a codemod script to
detect the code. We were able to fix about600
of them automatically because they the president
have interesting parent con instructors, four
hundred we had to fix manually. We do hack
tons everyone at Facebook, promised everyone
a t‑shirts, we had 400 call sites per person.
And we did it. Everyone got a T‑shirt, we
high fived each other, it was great. But the
whole point of this is that I want to point
out that codemods are not‑‑ they're
not going to solve all your problems but they're
really useful and assist you when you do manual
clean ups. what's the impact on Open Source.
It's important how we approach Open Source
at Facebook. We only Open Source what we use
in production and add scale. The React team
they're responsible for deploying new versions
of React inturnly on ever respousetory, they're
responsible for making sure that we move to
new APIs as fast as possible. And they're
making sure that we move fast even with breaking
changes. But we always use master. If master
is broken Facebook is broken. So this should
explain why we have invest in the this kind
of code tooling, we have a lot of React code
.
But the tooling is influenced how we approach
Open Source code, if you have looked at recent
release notes of React native or React, you
see that we actually published codes mods
for React and React DOM political up in 0.14
you can run a script if you have a large code
base and it will be fixed auto3459ically for
you. 24 is great. When we make breaking changes
and we can write you a script and up grayeds
your code automatically when you update your
version of React, the whole community wins.
And people have been really happy with this.
This person found this tool and in less than
two hours he safely transformed thousands
of lines of code, this is outside of opinion,
it's really cool. What I found about this
is that I recently rap a codemod on every
test file at Facebook. And a day later after
I made the changes I wanted to figure out
how many lines of code did I change. It was
40,000 lines of code, I didn't notice that
when I was doing the change, no problems,
all the tests are still running, everything's
great. One more tiny little thing, I'm sorry
we're a little bit over. Then Abramov was
asking for an on‑line babble editor, I was
like didn't I show you the same thing with
JS code shift. Do you want to see that really
quick? All right, this only takes ten seconds,
I promise. So here we just go into Babel.
And then what we're going to do is Translate
our Babel script to German, because that's
fun. That's it. Thank you so much for listening.
(Applause) wow, that was awesome. Thank you
so much. So we're just going to do a very
quick scene change here and bring up Thomas
who's got probably the better GitHub user
names, it's Watson and he's‑‑ come on
up, get set up, man. In the time honored tradition
of writing lots and lots NPM modules you can
see Thomas has written such hits as bay 64
and coding things as Emoji. Enabling the T‑Cup
protocol. On HTTP servers. While you guys
get settled, we'll just get set up here.